welcome to this video this will be part
two or episode two of them
chess openings uncovered series and I've
got a couple of requests for the
caro-kann um so yeah I'll do a video
maybe even two I'm not quite sure how
much I'm managed in one video about the
CARICOM um it will be young as mentioned
in the first video kind of overview I'm
not thinking about going into a huge
detail here this is not possible at the
time but I want to present an overview
what kind of lines there are and maybe
give some some hints where to look at
what to look at what lines to look at
them according to the position that
might arise so let's say you you're more
of a technical player or Morphin
attacking player then I would say okay
the so this line is maybe more suited to
you or this is salon that you can play
without knowing too many concrete lines
or whatever so let's get going the
caro-kann and won c-6 about against
money for the caracal is one of the main
replies against you for in general I'd
like to I like to categorize the replies
against 1.e4 into yeah into three groups
and these are the main moves which are
just roughly which oops
five c5e six nc6 so both en si pawn
moves other in my mind the first tier
defenses stuff like d6g six or nine f6
um yeah
slightly less solid but still okay and
yeah stuff like a six or b6 I don't know
b6 let's say it's simply second grade
and should give white an advantage
alright I forgot d5 as one of the sec
and second now second rate is too harsh
award so let's say not among the most
solid stuff but still very much okay
okay so c6 one of the best moves and
obviously is something that you can
always recommend to black players it's
very very good very good opening so
let's go through the lines of course
blacks ideas play d5 get a foothold in
the center and wide them almost always
place now one D form it's not mandatory
though there are alternatives just
briefly what else is there there is c4
which might after d5 transpose them into
the panel of attack usually arising
after two d4 d5 85 CD 5 c4 we see this
later
or it could arise this position where
white has damage to some front structure
but we'll get a very nice open piece
play um this is a good playable line you
need to be aware though that like after
c4 has ideas like this which is very
much not in one F or position it can
easily transpose into the King's Indian
or old Indian law any other line so you
better have some idea about these kind
of openings if you play to see form um
another important alternative is the two
knights variation an old favorite of
Bobby Fischer's it still played today um
by Nigel short he sometimes applies this
variation and it's it's quite
interesting it's a good alternative um
Black's main reply here is Bishop g4 and
very often white early on gets the
bishop pair but black has some very good
solid structure or pawns on white
squares the kurakin of course a white
square opening and you are you don't
have the bishop anymore so black is very
solid but white can of course play this
position it usually more for
strategic line and less tactical one
idea about this is also if black takes
here that the line with Bishop f5 which
is the main line after d5 if you had
this position with pawn on d4 Knight
back on g1 so let's just show this
quickly this is this position this is
the main line nowadays with the Knights
it's slightly different so the problem
here is that H for threatening h5 that
you have this kind of stuff coming and
this is some bit bit ugly to say the
least
black must play a g6 now you put it on
the board very ugly Queen f3 stuff like
that so it's a it's a bit tricky Bishop
f5 is the move that you want to want to
see here after ninety seven there's no
not much difference beside that you are
committed to the early night development
on f3 so it's it's a tricky line if you
um if you want to get out of the main
path early then it's it's it's an option
to consider also there's possible d3 the
Kings Indian attack star move of course
you cannot really expect to play for an
advantage with such a move cannot be the
best move just by biological principles
but it's certainly playable I played
this myself when I was yeah a lot
younger because I like the Kings Indian
attack very much and I had some pretty
good results with this kind of setup to
you you just continue let's say um black
plays Knight f6 not the best move
probably but the general ideas of course
too
to get this Kings Indian attack position
and if you enjoy this kind of from the
kind of setup you can certainly go for
this it's a nothing that would scab like
much though
especially after 92 black and play e5
and it's hard to imagine that why should
get anything too great against this
there are some funny ideas though this
kind of stuff like this you get an
isolated pawn position suddenly alright
this has the very very early deviations
okay but divorce my father may move and
also the move I would recommend white
players to to play d5
yeah and now of course them yeah black
simply attacks the e4 pawn and you don't
have much you have choices but you need
to take care about the e4 pawn other you
advance it to play the advanced care
account which is nowadays probably the
main line of the opening um the other
alternative is to play one of the knight
moves which is often not much of a
difference
Sokolov on all that's a tricky
alternative f3 the fantasy variation I'm
not quite sure why dis caught the
fantasy variation it covers in form then
there is the exchange just exchanging
and now developing a piece like Bishop
d3 all c4 the plan of attack leading to
very open positions so let's work from
the rail line some to the more common
ones of 65 f3 it's a pretty rare line
the fantasy variation but it has
received some some outings in the last
couple of years by but creative players
for for example Russian
I know I think he won this in 2011 young
nepo machi he plays this regularly with
lots of success then we have Yvonne show
played it recently with success it's
interesting it's a very tricky line
which has one very very good and
interesting feature this setup of pawns
prevents blacks Bishop to to develop and
this is one feature of the CARICOM that
this bishop very often can can be used
early simply to look at this this Bishop
now immediately gets into play and after
we just prevent that so black very often
needs to readjust him and in fact maybe
the main line here is the movie six wear
black immediately says ok I tried but I
don't get the bishop out and this very
often leads to interesting position of
white gets too long castles quickly and
then texts on the King side while black
plays on the Queen side the fantasy
variation is quite interesting I don't
think it has any huge huge problem
theoretically for white it it's
certainly not refutation of the crown
but if you are looking for slightly
offbeat solution to this opening and
enjoy your active creative play then
it's maybe the line for you and you
should be afraid to sacrifice pawns as
though because this is one of the main
lines but like instantly am threatens
Queen to h4 and this leads to two pure
gambit star play but you see that with
the open F file and the play on f7
yeah there's certainly very good
compensation for white it's very risky
for black to play this way but still you
need to be aware of that this is a sharp
line
I think the fantasy super dant is
underestimated but it gets some
popularity last couple of years so an
interesting way to play yeah look at
let's look at this next the exchange
with Bishop d3
very often this is played then and it's
um quite solid so solid choice for white
you've got a good open development only
Bishop move CSL black gum needs to do
something about the c8 bishop it cannot
go to to f5 but very often black cam
simply goes some along these lines and
get this Bishop out anyway
in general this structure is some quite
similar to the card spot structure and
the Queens gambit declined just was
color to the colors reversed so we've
got the C pawn exchanged for the e pawn
it's very similar to the Queen's Gambit
exchanged but here wide in comparison to
to the black side in the Queen's Gambit
exchange has got both bishops on active
positions in the corresponding line of
the Queen's Gambit exchange like only
gets this Bishop to to e7 and this
Bishop not out at all
so it's quite good if you enjoy open
positions but you shouldn't expect too
much from this black has already made
plan with a minority attack be pawn push
on amongst others and in general it
should be too scary for black but if you
want the simple position with clear
ideas white very often sets up very very
simply like this develop Knight to e5
and then try to play on the King side so
it's it's not bad at all but it's not
the most aggressive way to play alright
this is the exchange and now we got the
run of attack um yeah this is the choice
for players who would like to play with
open piece play yeah everything's wide
open here and don't mind to have an
isolated pawn very often you get
isolated pawns just for example
position like this it's fairly typical
if black plays work nor do you six black
has other choices but white um in almost
all lines get isolated pawns another
main move versus this year and it can
lead to quite quite sharp a play like
Bishop g5 G takes e5 on d5 and so on
it's very tactical and open so if you
enjoy peace play and like to UM like to
you have a dynamic kind of flowing
position with with pieces coming out
quickly then the panel is a good choice
it's also not so easy for black to play
he needs to know at least one good line
and he knows needs to know it really
well to avoid trouble
I'm theoretically speaking black should
be okay I mean black is okay in the
other opening so no wonder yeah but it's
um it's not not so easy to play that
same comparison to the pure exchange
variation of like simply needs to know
one setup and it's fine um yeah the pun
off is still a very good very good
weapon that can be recommended yeah for
black I think the most solid way to play
this as some probably this line
transposing to yeah very often transpose
into a crack on let's I have a look at
this to a caracal to a new Mizzou Indian
of course sorry to the names of Indian
Cup of variation quite fun to get from
the from the panel to the clerk to the
to the news oh but it happens here as
bishop it should be formed in this
position is the most solid way for black
to play and it probably is very close to
being being equal the sharper option is
96 or but this is a bit risky g6
if you want to get some more
enterprising players black then you
should go for g6 or 96 196 is probably
theoretically the healthier move
sic system still interesting yeah this
is what i would play as black probably
the 96 it's quite um quite sharp can get
quite sharp at least um yeah this is the
pun off and yeah what else is there they
are the two light booths and of course
the the advanced variation so yeah maybe
let's start with the night moves
yeah why are there those two moves i
mean what's the difference between 93
and oops and 92 of course if black takes
there is no difference there's a slight
difference if black decides not to take
which is possible and mostly with the
move g6 here we see a difference in the
setup with 92 g6 white actually has the
possibility to play c3 and secure the
center continue with Bishop d3 castles
and in the same position with Knight c3
g6 this is not possible we cannot play
c3 and this simply leads to different
positions for example if white now plays
Knight to f3 Bishop g7 then h3 is the
main move preventing Bishop to g4 and
then there are lines like this possible
not that this is particularly great for
black but this is possible and it's
simply a different position than with 92
and Bishop d3 early then this early
counter play is simply not possible for
black so it's very often not a huge
difference but if you know that your
opponent plays this kind of stuff you
need to consider which move you want to
play and check which lines to allow and
which lines to avoid very often it's no
difference as black takes anyway yeah
yeah black has of course quite a choice
he can play the main move Bishop f5 97
which is yeah not far behind in terms of
yeah popularity at least over the whole
span of the opening has been played
quite a lot Bishop f5 is a small often
played though and there's the
interesting move my deaf six which is
very rarely played but it is interesting
um let's start with this move often
called the Bronstein Larsen variation
Knight f6 obviously and White's wide to
take and he doesn't have any other move
ready to take and then black has a
choice of two recaptures he can play he
takes f6 which yet to be honest is not
completely correct opening I mean it's
playable but it's not not too great as
white enjoys the far 2/3 majority and
black has no bishop pair to compensate
this it's quite similar to the to the
reuleaux pass exchange just a mirror
image and this is simply yeah the the
basis f4 for lost phone and game in the
very distant future it is not losing by
force or anything but simply a bit
uncomfortable for black to play um in
general if black plays Knight f6 he
wants to go here and this is in fact a
quite interesting position and an
interesting line it has a bit forgotten
so basically never played by any top
player some see this very rarely but
it's very interesting I mean black has
very nice pawn
Massey in the center and he intends to
get the bishop out here here then play a
six and maybe play for long castles also
got the gioves the G file here so black
is quite active of course on the
structures not not too great cut pawn
weaknesses but it's a very interesting
sharp
with some really tricky variations this
is probably the main move c3 and now
black has the funny idea night quit to
g5 looks very strange but he wants to
play against the g3 setup which not have
Queen to d5 obviously does g3 is not
possible so just just the hint for black
players um have a look at this line it's
not so bad as it sometimes yeah believed
to be and it's an interesting
alternative to get a fighting position
especially if you if you also play one
of the solid lines 97 or Bishop f5 it's
maybe interesting to have Knight f6 as
as an offbeat alternative to surprise
white players they often simply forgot
what to play against this because it's
so rarely played yeah and then 97 which
is has been couples favorite move blacks
ideas to prepare Knight f6 and here on
the main lines are Bishop c4 or nowadays
by far Knight to g5 935 is a funny move
it looks rather weird but one point is
that the move is h6 is in fact a huge
mistake after 96 and well this leads to
checkmate even black cannot take but so
he needs to move the Queen somewhere and
after this why does one the bishop pair
and yeah somehow this whole position
looks a bit a bit yeah out of rhythm for
black so it's strange so h6 is not
really good very often it continues like
this still h6 is no good and it often
leads to this kind of this kind of
position
we're black later tries to play c5 or b6
Bishop d7 c5 yeah I'm not 100% sure and
I think I'm this should be it somewhere
between equal and a slight advantage to
white it's certainly playable for
blanket but it's not so popular anymore
um did I get the move on alright let's
hear ye six no is this you first not
Queenie - because after age six you can
take here this is the famous deep blue
against Kasparov sacrifice like a
sparrow for whatever reason went for
this completely lost line as black um
okay the alternative here is Bishop c4
Knight f6 Knight g5 which is a bit
similar but this other kind of one that
I showed before is maybe a little bit a
little bit more testing for black here
white is threatening on f7 so black
needs to invest in move here and then we
got something like this a general
feature here is that black didn't manage
to get the bishop out but instead it
sort of looks a bit like a French but
was slightly weird piece placement oh
this is certainly playable for black all
ranging from some a very slight
advantage for white to equality okay but
the big move here by far is Bishop f5
and I think it's very understandable
that this move is the most popular
simply because it solves this issue
about of the bishop immediately getting
it out and now Knight G 3 is some - the
main move if you're looking for an
offbeat alternative not C 5 is not too
bad it yeah funny enough attacks this
pawn there are some some technical lines
with E 5 or 97
but this is playable it has been played
by some strong players in the last
couple of years and might help to get a
lesson explored position nothing to be
afraid of her black though I mean black
is very fine in this opening my g3
Bishop g6 and now this is the the main
continuation nowadays this kind of setup
and in fact this whole line has been
played since I don't know maybe the 50s
or 60s and it always had the reputation
of being I was very slightly better for
white and this is mostly in the setups
where let's put it on the god bishop
here if six castles Queen c7 C form long
castle so a black castles long I'm not
quite sure if this is the 100% correct
use order but if not it's close and the
black castles long and this always had
the reputation of being slightly passive
for black you get in c5 later but all in
all you don't have much count to play
very often white get got slightly better
positions you've got more room as white
and sometimes have ideas on the kingside
later not in the middle game but more in
the endgame where this pawn is a bit of
a nuisance for black asset sort of Hema
slipped upon cm the whole yeah I cannot
pronounce this word the whole are let's
say oops I didn't want to do that oops
the whole revival of this line came with
the idea of actually not playing for
long castle but but going for for short
slang so this kind of setup and then
canceling short and this is nowadays the
main line of the the yeah the classical
Farrakhan with 93 or 92 um yeah this is
some in fact a rather can get rather
sharp because after short castles White
has this ready made an attack idea with
g4 g5 of course this night obstruct this
but this is the idea and yeah black will
get counter play with c5 probably rooks
e8 Queen out and so on so it's it is
rather sharp but I think all in all
black is believed to be pretty okay here
but if you play black you need to be
ready to to yeah getting attacked really
with G 45 I tried to play this opening a
couple of and said yes ago I let's say
what he wanted a half two years ago and
I am I simply found out that for me I'm
I don't know I'm always getting nervous
about 3:45 stuff it's probably okay I
mean it is it is okay suddenly but you
really no need to know what you're doing
it's not the kind of line that you can
just play and hope you're right
it's some it's dangerous for white
player suddenly you can look at this and
try to work out a good kind of move
order to get in this G 45 at once it's
it's rather sharp it's not not no boring
whatever kind of maneuvering opening
distance can get really sharp um but all
in all black should should be okay I
mean the the main sign that black is
okay in this line is that nowadays if
you look at world-class players they the
absolute top young they basically almost
all of them play the advanced and this
is simply because the other lines are
pretty much fine for black here they're
simply maybe a little bit more to find
in terms of selling black problems
what you need to be aware of if you want
to play this as black though shouldn't
forget this that in this position white
isn't obliged to play this h4 h5 9 f3
he has other ideas he can play stuff
like this all night
e 2 on night h3 and the idea is very
often to put pressure on this Bishop
with a knight and then follow up with h4
or maybe Bishop c4 getting on on f7 in
some ways um
you need to know this lines they are not
without a drop of poison if you don't
don't know what you're doing there you
can get into trouble really quickly so
you need to know your stuff I think the
the main point is nowadays that like
very quickly plays some quick Bishop d6
so that you can get quickly on on this
night it's ok but um this these are
sight lines but you need to know them as
black certainly and like that can be
interesting for Wyatt I mean it's very
easy to forget those kind of sad lines
if you are busy learning them the main
lines okay so this is the classical I
call the Night Moves the classical I'm
not quite sure this is so right term
okay and then there's the advanced
variation which is as mentioned nowadays
probably the main line black young has
two main Museum the absolute main lines
Bishop f5 but this is also the funny
move c5 which is he indeed funny black
it instantly
tries to prepare Knight to c6 but loses
a who tempo in the process was c5 the
main point is autumn a problem let's say
here's some that yeah it's some in some
lines you simply yeah get this pawn
taken and you don't get it back so
quickly um it's quite an ambitious line
or c5 but it seems to be playable
and there's in fact I'm a German
Grandmaster now German for me I think
Russian Igor chenkin who's playing this
all the time I mean against all people
even to seven 2700 GM's and against
preparation he's willing to play this
all the time and he's not the kind of
person who allows them yeah to allow
some a bad position to happen knowingly
so he needs to he knows what he's doing
usually in the opening so maybe this is
an interesting way for black to to get
out of the the main um the main path
here because they are really complicated
and there's a lot to learn so an
interesting try for for black maybe for
white I will say that I think nowadays
there are these kind of ideas with very
quick opening of the position and I
think maybe this is interesting to look
at for white but if you are next
it's very much possible that if you're
an expert on the caro-kann you already
know that this is maybe not the best I'm
just telling you what I know that this
at least was critical one or two years
ago probably still is but I'm not 100%
sure it's interesting okay the main
point here is Bishop FM's
the main move here is Bishop f5 of
course and after this white has some a
really wide choice of moves and
basically they're there to kind of to be
our two or three kind of plans iam
there's some the kind of crude plan to
attack this Bishop and this can happen
with moves like g4 online c36 g4 or it
can happen with white starting h4 and
black maybe replying h6 and then g4 so
white can tribe in a very sharp manner
to attack this Bishop um and these kind
of moves are always interesting and
sharp but I don't think
any of them are too dangerous or they're
dangerous but they're not a huge threat
to to black maybe you need to know what
you're doing though let's say this ng
form the vendor vo variation this habit
has been really popular in the 90s and
and after that and I think nowadays is
it's mostly considered ok for black
g-form
Bishop g6 and I think 92 was was the
main the main roof water here but I
think nowadays I think c5 is pretty okay
for black and this is some for white
players it can be recommended to play
this way if you really like super sharp
and yeah let's say yeah irrational
positions I mean it's the pure pure lock
faced sometimes and black has many
alternatives you can also play stuff
like this for example it's not a bad
move on h5 sometimes it's it's very
sharp but you need to know as wide that
you're really burning your bridges and
you need to know what you're doing if
black knows the stuff well and you don't
know anything you will lose the game at
some Blaz net it's very sharp and then
there's the I think the instant g4 has
is not really dangerous
I think it's h4m it's the more more
dangerous way to play this black and
even very often just with you to do 7
and set up a French set up and ask you
what what the hell are you doing with
the opponent you fall I don't even g4 in
some DSS any dangerous and h4 is an
interesting move and this is actually a
move I'm I could recommend to my players
at some it's quite tricky at times and
so it's sharp but it's not completely
yeah I mean Knight c3 energy for the
vendor will assess it's on the it's
close to being a bit on unsolved yeah
unsound and it's not not losing or
anything but you really risk
a lot and this is not the case of h1h
form tries to put pressure on the bishop
just as the other moves to so black sgsn
as he threw three days but black here is
six is not possible at all as you simply
will lose the bishop head it doesn't
have any any squares so black needs to
react in a way and very often you react
was h5 if he goes h6 you can even play g
form you shoot back and then e six this
had been featured recently and i in a
game i presented on the channel between
our music truck and and emails of toski
and a fantastic technical game played
just two months ago and so am i can um
maybe put a note here in the video to to
link to this a really great game in this
line um black also and in fact more
often plays h5 to which white plays see
form and then tries to attack the center
with the sea porn and this leads to a
very complicated battle in which you if
you know a couple of month lines or
things you can play without knowing too
many concrete concrete things it's quite
interesting for white and I think
something to recommend I think there are
some players who often play h4 for
example Peter swig la place this move
often yeah each fall it's an interesting
way for white to go and black probably
should play h5 it's just more solid than
h6 but h6 probably playable as well um
okay though these are the somewhat
sharper options and then there are some
a whole group of lines which white can
play that are more firm strategical
nature they can get sharp as well and
but this is not f3 first and foremost
and also the moves you should III see
three on 92 in fact all these moves my
transpose into the same position it's
quite irritating at times the most plate
one is not f3 and this is nowadays
called the short variation as Nigel
short really a popular popularized the
smooth starting from the early 1990s and
it was quickly picked up by an by and
lots of top players on with this move
white basically says ok you have your
Bishop out of the out of the pawn chain
but they don't mind I just developed
quickly and all this leads to a French
where you lose and move with C 65 and
you get your Bishop out but big deal
I'll exchange it off very often with not
h4 not at the moment yeah the queen is
covering the square but often this
Bishop will get exchanged and then I get
the bishop BAM
and well I don't mind that you get the
bishop out of this and quite often and
this is a very interesting feature on
the the bishop out of the pawn chain is
not only an advantage but also problem
for black because some I can I can show
an align be should be too
let's say black go c5 and now Bishop
here and let's let's just consider this
pawn is hanging and if black takes which
is a playable booth then you see that
this noida text the bishop a black needs
to react to this he cannot allow his
pawn structure to being completely
destroyed here so 97 and then white can
very often open up the position with c4
and Queen b3 stuff like this and there
you see that the Queen side has been
weakened by this Bishop being out of the
pawn chain also White has quite
considerable lead and development
already
um so on the short variation can get
sharp quickly if wide opens up the
position we'll see form um it's probably
the main line of the calc on nowadays
and certainly align that white players
should investigate black players
obviously as well you get it very often
when I tried out the caro-kann in in
online Blitzer on ICC and on other
platforms I got the advance all the time
much more than I got and the knight
moves or the panel for whatever so I'm
black of course has a multitude of
possibilities again play this Knight
moves first or c5 immediately is
probably the main move yeah
then there are lines which are similar
in nature one is 92 I just want to show
the idea here white quickly gets the
Knight to b3 and this way tries to make
it harder for black to get to get in c5
it can if you look at this here this
kind of development is very similar to
the short system but here white um yeah
it doesn't open up the position early he
wants to hit the black from playing his
c5 break and this is very much playable
as well black here nowadays often goes
for this kind of maneuvers pretty
interesting um in general this these
lines are very very interesting from a
strategical point of view and if you are
more inclined to play a sort of slower
game where you don't need to memorize
those direct confrontation online and
this is a good good choice um in fact
there's also this move which if you look
at this my transpose it's just been
different with the bishop out early
in fact if you want to play this opening
ass black I think it's really necessary
to to look at games here and then study
the kind of plans and the different move
orders that that white comes up with as
it can be sometimes very irritating and
for white players I suggest that you
that you study those move orders also
and try to pick something where black
has to be careful this early Bishop III
in fact has one one point that it allows
some an early F form to to both so the
center here and this is of course a
difference to an early night f3 and yeah
as you as you already saw there are a
ton of variations after Bishop f5 and
this is also why I wanted to point out
this move as it might be a good
alternative if you want to simply a.m.
yeah save up on learning lines here you
are the one to get in the surprise very
often it is really a surprise to what
players they don't know know exactly
what is happening if you get in the the
the novelty on the Northeast also but
you you're the one to to put the game
into the the kind of waters that you
know better probably than your opponent
and this is why this move is interesting
after Bishop f5 that's really a ton of
lines that you need to need to memorize
I'm pretty sure even forgot one because
there's there's so much did I really
forget one I mean there's really
everything's playable in a way yeah
there's also these this old booth but
this is really harmless blackened
exchange quickly this exchanges so it
was always very fine for black so for
white players you can if you want to
have a sharper more unbalanced battle
maybe h4 is a good idea and if you want
to have to play it this way you have
those sharp ideas with c4 depending on
on what black is is playing now it's
really a difference if he
place c5 then c4 is it's a good idea to
open up the position and make use of the
the the weekend coincide if black plays
oops if black plays and snow move then
very often it can transpose into this
kind of setup and it's more for
maneuvering game yeah that wants us so
nowadays the main battleground and
become constantly because of yeah the
very solid reputation of the Bishop f5
line after Knight to c3 our 92 but it's
also I'm very interesting from a
strategic point of view for both sides
to play I think black um yeah good
investigators mentioned the c5 idea here
to get out of this this really huge
theory or you really need to bite the
bullet and to learn some stuff against
all this it's it's very it can be rather
difficult to play this without any
concrete knowledge and I managed to lose
quite a number of blitz games in this
opening us black against people who knew
what they're doing and sometimes I was
really not getting any kind of playable
position it it's not looking so this
kind of stuff oops like the short
variation it doesn't look so threatening
at first but it can be really really
tough if you want to learn more about
this line I can refer you to games of
Sega cockiness playing this really
excellently with white in general a book
recommendation for the Carcano opening
is some very very good book by a last
shondo office wrote a book on the
CARICOM for black dialysis and
recommendation for black and he in this
book recommended ya to go Bishop f5 here
obviously with short castles basically
this is the modern caro-kann wati wati
am recommended in the book Bishop f5 in
the advance he he went for
five main lines and in the pan off the
big three so the same oops
no not that happy six is terrible like
ninety six also the most dynamic choice
so we constructed the Karen repertoire
which is more on the dynamic side more
on the dynamic than the solid side I can
post the link also in the description
too to this book it's very much the
standard book now on the caro-kann for
black at least and very much recommended
if you want to pick up this opening yeah
this was very much content in one video
I hope you enjoyed it and I'll be back
with more of this openings uncovered and
yeah keep on posting suggestions so as
you see it I pick them up and really do
something about the suggestions yeah
cheers and by me